Film Courage: If we look at Forrest
Gump does he have defining moments?
Christopher Riley, Screenwriter,
Author, and Instructor: Wow,
that's a really interesting question.
So Forrest, he experiences a moment that doesn't
transform his inner nature his inner nature is
is constant he is he's an innocent that's
his genius but when the movie opens he's
an innocent alone and the moment that he
climbs onto the school bus and meets Jenny
defines his life his life will never be the same
after that moment that he climbs onto the school
bus and in fact there's dialogue in the film where
he says it's I can't quote it but it's it's funny
what a a person remembers I don't remember my
first pair of shoes etc he says but I do remember
the first time I heard the sweetest voice in
the whole wide world and he meets Jenny on
the bus she invites him to sit beside her and
he says in very defining moment language from
that moment on we was like peas and carrots so he
experiences a moment that defines him even though
it doesn't redefine his inner nature it defines
his experience of life I think that when Forrest
finds out he's got a son that is a
transforming moment it redirects the
course of his life his life will now
be about caring for a little Forrest
and I think that Jenny's death it is also
probably a defining moment for him because
his life at least as told in the movie is
bookended by meeting Jenny and then losing Jenny
but receiving from her the gift of his son and
that then will define the rest of Forrest's life
so defining moments don't always
transform say the nature of a person
but they can still change the course of
of their lives I think we see that with
Jack in Titanic Jack is not a character who
really has a big need to grow and change
Rose definitely needs to be transformed
when we meet Rose she's ready to
leap off the back of the ship to her death by the
time the movie's done Rose is all about surviving
so she has been transformed Jack
is still kind of the same guy
but I think we could say that meeting Rose is a
defining moment for Jack and if he had not met her
his certainly those whatever three or four
days of the voyage would have been different
and while that sounds like a short period of
time that was that was his whole life that
was all the life he had left he might also say
winning that card game that got him the ticket
on Titanic would also be a defining event in
his life yeah so with Forrest Gump it seems as
if there were maybe stronger in some sense turning
point like in terms of the defining moments that
changed a lot of the people because if you
look at Lieutenant Dan he was so angry he was
so competitive he had so much vengeance and then
toward the end when you see him at the wedding
he's he's a different person he's
transformed yes so for Lieutenant Dan
his life was on a clear course toward what
he thought was his destiny which was to
die heroically in battle which that was what
his family did and Forrest intervened and pulled
him out of danger and disrupted the course that
Lieutenant Dan thought his life was supposed to be
on so that was a moment that redefined Lieutenant
Dan 's life in a way Lieutenant Dan despised and
then Lieutenant Dan was on that course of being
completely unhappy with a life that he saw as
he's been cheated so all he's got now is just
emptiness until he is on the shrimping boat
in the middle of the hurricane with Forrest and he
climbs up the mast in the middle of that hurricane
and has a screaming match with god over his
destiny and Forrest tells us that in that moment
he believes that god and Lieutenant Dan somehow
came to peace with each other and Lieutenant
Dan is a different person after that which makes
possible Lieutenant Dan showing up at the wedding
now he's got new legs he has a wife and he's no
longer the bitter person he's been made whole
and we within the movie we have the two pivot
points the rescue which denied him his destiny
and then the confrontation between Lieutenant
Dan and god in the midst of a hurricane
which then makes his growth possible so
we can only understand Lieutenant Dan 's
character arc through those two pivot points and
then with Jenny here she recommends for Forrest
to run to run from the bullies but really that's
a metaphor for what she'd been doing all her life
and so we don't see her toward the end
until she comes back and she's changed
but we just know that she was a runner
herself and then she's much different
yes and in many ways the moment that
made it possible for her to come home
happened off screen we we understand well we
see her hit bottom when she when she climbs up
on that railing of a balcony at a new year's
eve party I think and so we understand that
either we've seen a defining moment or that she
is in the zone where those things kind of happen
her return to forest is evidence that she has
had this transformative kind of experience
but I think it shows us
that defining moments can be
kind of if we're talking about playing cards
they can be played in different ways they can
be played on screen off screen through just a
character recounting something that happened or
we end up with more defining moments than we can
actually use it's one of my frustrations I was
working today on my next feature screenplay
and the last two pages after fade out
are a nice little dialogue scene that tells the
story of my main character's defining moment and I
know that that's going to fall out of the script
because it just it doesn't need to be in there
but I needed to know what that moment was
so that I could write the rest of
what that character says and does
so even when these defining moments don't end
up on screen they still enrich my understanding
this is also something that can be really valuable
for actors for them to understand not only
that this is true of my character
but why this is true of my character
so I’ll tell a story out of school when I worked
at warner brothers in the script department
the movie Twister started shooting
before the script was fully written
and producer Ian Bryce called me up and said
can you send a script typist to Oklahoma
to work with the writer as he finishes
writing this movie while we shoot it
and I said that sounds like too much fun I’ll
send myself so I was on a plane the next day
to Oklahoma City and I ended up out in the middle
of a farm field with 300 vehicles and making this
big tornado action movie Helen Hunt plays a
meteorologist who's chasing tornadoes obsessively
for reasons that no one knew at the moment
because that scene hadn't been written yet
so she's having to go out and try she's trying
to put this scientific instrument place it in
the path of a tornado so it'll be sucked up
and they'll learn all kinds of things about
tornadoes she's putting her life at risk putting
her relationships at risk and at some point they
know will write the scene for her backstory the
defining moment that made her a tornado hunter but
they didn't need to film that for several weeks
into the future and they didn't seem to take
into account that Helen Hunt as an actor would
like to know why she's doing all these things
eventually they came up with what we would
describe as a defining moment a moment from
her childhood when she experienced a killer
tornado and that birthed in her the dream
that she would someday make the world safer by
getting people more advance warning of tornadoes
my argument is it would have been a real service
to Helen Hunt as an actor to know what that was
while she was chasing those tornadoes and that
I'll just use as a metaphor for the way that
an understanding of defining moments can
be of use and a value to actors certainly
directors editors cinematographers
everyone I described
the way Michael Corleone is in the bathroom in
that pivotal defining moment for the godfather
you can see evidence that everyone on the
team appreciated what that moment meant for
that character and for the film the production
designer had to design three sets of doors for
the character to walk through the cinematographer
had to arrange the shot that way the editor the
composer had to all support that moment not cut
past it because oh my gosh how much time are we
spending in this bathroom nothing's going on in
here but everybody recognized that yes this is
where Michael is going through this metamorphosis
and so we have to support and dramatize
all of the interaction that is happening outside
of our view somehow we have to make that visible
on the screen and the entire team understood
intuitively or not what a defining moment that was
and built an entire film around
that moment we've talked a lot about
defining moments in drama but in comedy as well I
mean we could think of so many John Hughes films
that had great defining moments whether it was
16 Candles or Home Alone or something I mean
there's just is there a difference in the
way that a comedic defining moment is done
I think I am not a comedy writer I it just gives
me terrible anxiety to think about exchanging
money for laughs and I have friends who specialize
in comedy I think it's a gift that I don't have
but to the extent that I understand comedy
comedy works a lot like drama except it's just
funny we laugh so when a character is pursuing
a goal they pursue it to absurd lengths
in a way that you wouldn't do in
a drama but the character arcs
still often have to do with
character transformation
I think that the deepest and and like most
satisfying comedies really are dramas with laughs
and so I think that these defining moments
absolutely exist you might need a moment
a defining moment to help us understand why a
character would do the absurd things that they do
but so that they may be a of a different
quality when I brainstorm my 20 possibilities
i'm going to pick a different defining moment
in a comedy than I am in a gritty drama
just for tone but it's still performing
those functions of either explaining
why the hero wants what they want why they
need to grow and change the way they need to
or that's showing us the transformation
as it unfolds step by step.